it's lovely to be here in this this
country following uh following my drink
you following your dream what's your
what do you do
you work in HR [__] dream get that
dream
how many people you fired this year
a lot yeah because she's good at her job
[__] you okay
she didn't want to fire those people
maybe some of them but not all of them
you know what industry are you
life science
yeah I still don't understand what that
means
bio farmer wow great that's pretty
[__] cool is it taking a real hit
this year that you've had to fire people
or just loss of sexual harassment
tribunals
those bio farmers are pretty handsy let
me tell you
when when you were a little one what
what did you want to be grown up
presumably not an HR person in
Bahia farmer
a vet what's your favorite
non-domesticated animal
a tiger [__] yeah you ever met a tiger
a pretty [__] orange and so I can
tell you
great so you want to be a vet he became
an HR person in in biopharma
um I mean you're the people who are with
you are sat smiling as if they're
achieving their goals
um are you a skateboard video director
what do you do
you do data
data analysis
why are you a sort of that was like oh
no we didn't
um
and and so you just look at stuff and
you just tell people what that stuff
means
yeah why does your job exist right
it's a ruse most jobs are a ruse right
you know I feel comedy is a ruse I think
like we've all got funny friends and I
guess they just weren't available
tonight so
you came here
some parasocial [__] um
I'm grateful very grateful
growing up what did you want to do
astronaut cool which planet did you want
to go to
probably like sound yeah aim big the
planet you cannot land on just
they say it's a gas giant but I reckon I
could
those Rings look pretty sturdy to me
actually
gentlemen in them in the middle wearing
all black and a prominent belt buckle
which
which mafia do you work for
I can't wait to hear the accents like oh
where is he where's he from Albanian
former Yugoslavian
a bit of Florida mafia oh [__] that
sounds like you've actually got t-shirts
made up that say that from a bachelor
party you went on back in 2004 with your
buddy Dirk
[Applause]
so that's that's in your in your in your
dream life what would you actually do
it
oh thank you for not lying as well
do you have I reckon you have root can I
touch your hands
they're not as soft as I hoped
it people usually have soft fingers but
now I think you may have buried a corpse
and then uh partner of the the Florida
mafia what's what's when you when you
were a little one what did you dream of
being
you wanted to be a physical therapist
and you are a physical therapist what a
type of physical there my mother is a
why are people applauding just like you
don't know what type of physical therapy
she does
she might be like you walk really well
let's change that
my husband's in the Florida mafia and
he's got a golf club
Orthopedics that's
[Music]
um
post-op Orthopedics
well I don't understand what it means
they have to learn functions
like hips to knees
she helps them with the confidence
[__] they love you they love you
right
okay well thank you thank you for the
explanation I appreciate that so someone
who wanted to be a physical therapist is
a physical therapist someone who is in
the Florida mafia I.T slash area
skateboard music director who is uh in
in data analysis and wanted to be an
astronaut and go to Saturn and then you
who fire people but you you aspire to me
to Tiger well um I
but it's just important that you know
these people because we're going to
immortalize these people right now in
the medium that I I treasure which is
growing up I wanted to be a rapper that
was
that was my dream I I achieved that so
do me a favor DJ drop that beat get that
spinning because yeah we're gonna do a
freestyle there's a rat made up on the
spot based entirely on this conversation
that just took place all improvised not
written not prepared not rehearsed and
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking about
don't worry it won't be as [__] as
you're expecting it to be it's gonna be
fun and we'll start with with you I
think cool give me your fingers again
hold it Aloft there's no plan got my
Florida mafia guy yes soft hand man I
see the fingers short and stubby elastic
ring your neck leave your corpse so
bloody down in the Panhandle yeah we
catch me saying gonna dig a shallow
grave in Tallahassee I'm taking you down
pay your debts but actually I.T how nice
can you get I'm sitting at my computer
yes I'm really on there look at this
typing oh I've got to monitor a picture
of my lady yes it's meant to be spent
her whole life physical therapy I see
her and I say I need it she helps people
with the Orthopedics what does it mean I
ask these girls they're like she
improves people in this world she shows
them how to walk how to turn how to move
down the street yeah they have to
relearn I broke my leg my hip and my
ankle can you help your yes you'll stand
up tall once again this is what you do I
thought Orthopedic was a type of shoe
just something they build up the soul
but you inflate the soul that's my
lady's goal now the table here how good
can you get as a five-year-old you will
like I'll be the best vet I'm walking
there for sure I'm gonna help orange
cats out in India they've got the orange
and the black stripes these are those
nice big cats that I like probably you
watch Lion King and The Jungle Book and
thought this is incredible but your
foundations were Shook You Realize best
is pretty depressing it's basically
killing animals and teaching them a
lesson oh this dog is far too old we
need to wait here till it's fur turns
cold sorry though we had to kill Fido
they put down the pet so you let it lie
low and then you realize something you
aspired basically you're like yeah your
pet's life is fired fired fired you're
losing your job I feel all the power
like an HR I've got walking in there no
cost for alarm you walk in some weird
section to buy a farm dark Clive was
coming in and he says I just wanted to
expose my penis head at the lady that I
like no sexual assault oh no I'm just
Clive yes and it's your fault off you go
but then here your shirt is mate looking
fantastic like he loves to direct skate
videos with Bam Margera and Tony Hawk he
was there as a child before he could
even walk his light year I'm gonna
[__] go past the asteroid belt [__]
Mars [__] the ones where you might melt
I'm going far away I'll be flattering
all this [__] Jupiter Sans where I'm
heading with the Rings like I'm winning
the Super Bowl yo even though it's tiny
little crumbs up there and they flow
around the orbit it's just blocks of ice
but you thought you could do it now my
advice is to give up on that hope and
dream and just stick their F in the
cream and in the cash from the stuff
that you do with the data I'm not being
cruel I'm not being a hater I'm sure
it's really important not cutting down
to size you sit there every day and you
analyze and you're like yes I'm
important to the company look at all the
work that I do in front of me you get
reported for Skyping on the job you have
to walk to the lady and she's like oh my
God we're friends this is awkward I've
always admired you that sadly in HR I'm
gonna have to fight
thank you